like if you choose to go into like a
city in a nightclub like men are
assaulted too men can get punched get
into fights if they're so it's like we
both have problems but more often than
not I'm I mean this is very generalizing
but if a man gets into an altercation
with another man more often than not
this is very generalizing but in the
terms of a situation like in a nightclub
or whatever so say I was in a night club
before two guys got into a fight that
was an altercation between them two like
being men they were fighting they were
arguing it was violent whereas like if
an altercation happened with a woman it
would be because he was such a
inappropriate that she was saying no
stop it and he would get angry because
he couldn't get the way he wanted can I
can I give you a stat that you might not
know yeah so so so so so let's let's
talk about abusive relationships so most
abusive relationships are or they're
both abusive meaning the man's hitting
the woman and the woman's hitting the
mat but in in cases where it's one-sided
abuse meaning someone's hitting and the
other is not hitting back women do it
more than men okay
so it's like when I see stats like this
and it's still like that women are
impressed like because I really think
men have a hard time coming forward when
they're assaulted by men so so I'll give
you another example tonight I'm here
with Jesse right and Jesse was literally
like we got it on camera this girl was
like pushing him and like all over him
and if that happened to me like I they
would cry assault right but for him like
nobody says anything yeah and so it's
like like girls can kind of get away
with that stuff where guys everyone
agrees it's wrong I do think that's a
hard statistic come by because
realistically like the difference is
even a night she's trying to get girls
to come forward and be like what you're
saying is wrong like you're not really
advocating for women's rights and even
the women are too afraid to come over to
you and talk to you well I don't know
why they're afraid like it's quite like
I don't know
[Music]
yeah because you are personally not even
like am I am I rude to you like I've
been quite polite to me but like to the
women you you have been rude uh how have
I been rude when someone threatened to
punch me okay but I know it hasn't
fashioned trying to punch you yeah but
she said I don't want to be near you
like that's kind of rude right it is
kind of weird but when you're like I'm
asking that hair experience of being
touched in a club where she didn't want
to be touched it's invalid you were
saying oh I didn't say it was invalid
that's not what I said okay but you kind
of push her away and neglected it like
it's not really an issue like you wanted
to talk about men I'm saying I'm saying
I don't think that's okay I don't I
think that's wrong but when you go out
into a nightclub like you know there's a
possibility that'll happen but there
shouldn't be a possibility I'm saying
I'm saying it happens to men and women
it happens to both like like just today
I went out with Jesse right and I I was
threatened right Jesse protected me that
was a privilege as a woman that I got
this girl comes up to him and has his
hands all over her hands all over him
like because he's a guy people just
accept it yeah I know I don't think
people accept it it's a hard but I think
as a woman it's more often that it
happens I don't know because men are
more likely statistics so I guess I'm
just gonna have to go because I I don't
really know enough to kind of battle
with you on there yeah yeah okay I think
I appreciate I appreciate your knowledge
like I understand that you have more
like knowledge
is it better to be a black person or a
white person in 2022 why
in jobs and everything like that if you
do like certain careers in University
you're more likely to excel than if
you're a bit of a black person but I I
also love him but I wouldn't change it
either I'm thinking more systematic
system so I'm fresh right so this is
about it's quite impressed you know it's
racism right like as in you can get a
job I could be a lawyer I could be a
doctor but getting higher in your
position really counts on the color of
your skin let's be real yeah and and not
not only because as your skills too but
mostly they are going to look at the
color of your skin and if you do get
into higher position most of the time
you are a token you know I I work we're
drunk so forgive us there's no right or
wrong answer right we're just having
conversations but you know I work in
finance and you know I'm doing decently
for myself at the moment right now
there's no programs that help white
people get jobs like maybe white women
yeah don't you think because that's
because I feel like that a part of that
is because they need to push it to show
that we're not racist and I don't know
if I'm a conspiracist or whatever you
want to call it like I do understand
they're like oh black women in power
like there was even like I think a
Barclays it was a bank I can't remember
which bank it was but there was a bank
that was helping women start business
and my brother sent it to me and I
remember it's like it's just like oh
black women in higher education but I
feel like a part of that is just to make
sure like the bank shows or like the the
government shows oh we're not racist by
the way like we do support black women
but unfortunately if you look at the
statistics black black people or people
of color are unfortunately poorer like
this is really scary because this is
what we were saying that um you know
black people probably statistically the
people at the bottom tend to be white so
if you go to the Northern parts of the
country they tend to be the poor areas
and those 10 people I think like they
are trying in that in the sense of all
the programs helping black people
start like getting into their careers
and things like that but additionally I
think it's long overdue I think that
this should have been started a long
time ago so what do you mean by a song
overview like um we're in 2022 like they
should have been helping black black
people
um
do you think quotas are racist like
programs like specifically for like
black people are racist because it's
basically saying like you can't do this
on your own we need to give you a
special program
but because
because of institutionalized racism it's
harder for us to do things on our own
like we will go to a job and there'll be
let's say five black people and five
black people I feel that it's a higher
chance of white people that the white
person will get the job done a black
person and I feel like these these
programs do enable us to further our
careers but I feel like wait as my
friend said we are in 2022 so I feel
like um this should have been done
overdue so I understand what you're
saying however when you look at
universities that tend to do these sorts
of things so if you go to Yale or the
top universities in America where they
have affirmative action a lot of the
black students that get through um get
through to the university because of
affirmative action tend to do very badly
because they thought out of the depth
because obviously those are the top one
percent of people in in that country
that are allowed in that University and
in comparison the top 10 of black people
are in there might not be doing as well
well it's like basically teaching black
kids to feel stupid because they they
could be so smart but they're at the
wrong school go ahead can I just say
quickly like if a black person gets them
to yell or Harvard or something or
anything like that they are a very small
minority of the University they don't
have people who are around them that
looks like them that acts like them that
are able to further them in their career
they feel like they're out of place so
that sets them down automatically I feel
like yeah also because in general out of
the population there's less black people
so of course you'll see less black
people at those institutions
institutions
education I just feel like black people
are already like that's a whole new
level already at a lower amount of
University as a whole and when you look
at in a university as a whole it needs
higher education when you look at black
people and white people are already at a
lower minority in the beginning so when
you as a black person as we walk into a
university and we see less of our people
we're gonna feel shy we're gonna feel
unable to come forward and really voice
up and that's and and probably that's
why most of the universities now have
ACS because tell me what distinguished
group you have for white people you
don't but then like don't you try to say
like hey you're included but don't you
think that if there was a group for
specifically for white people you'd be
calling it racist no no no you might not
you might not but a lot of people would